tonight
hi I'm Rickett I'm my name is Bradley
Gordon
um and I'm an advisor to the the
Cambodian government to the ministry of
culture
I understand that back in 94 your
company had an option of chimera
Antiquities and we just trying to figure
out where those pieces ended up one of
them is extremely important to Cambodia
that it was looted from a temple we've
collected a lot of testimony about it
what we've been doing the last two weeks
three weeks we've been going around the
states and we've been visiting museums
we've been to about 12 museums we went
to Asian Art Museum and Museum of Fine
Arts in Boston and Brooklyn Art Museum
and so on
okay
okay I mean totally I mean Super
appreciate that that's that's fantastic
okay thank you very much okay okay take
care bye
it's basically confiscating it
um
one of the dealers who probably was the
one
product many of these to the auction
um he died about a
something about two two years ago
Douglas latchford I don't know if you've
heard of him
the statue need to go back home because
the statue symbol asked the Cambodian
ancestor
as a Cambodian gods
every time you go to Temple we expect to
see the god over there to see our
ancestor over there but when we go to
the temple if we didn't see anything
over there people chop it out and then
cut the neck cut the legs and then move
away from from the temple and then to
the broker and to the dealer and to
collectors
this country was racked by Civil War for
a 30-year period from the late 60s to
the late 90s
Millions died Millions were made
refugees
and in that time this cultural heritage
was stolen a huge scale
the temples are some of the most
spectacular ancient sites you can
encounter the one most people are
familiar with is zangor I believe it's
right to call it the largest religious
complex in the world it is absolutely
enormous these very large statues
they're you know four and five feet tall
some of them they're incredibly
beautiful they're the product obviously
of immense skill and a lot of really
impressive artisanship
most people however would only have seen
them in museums because the statues are
all gone and that's because they were
all stolen the Denver Art Museum is now
returning four artifacts back to
Cambodia after they were linked to a man
who was indicted by prosecutors two
years ago Douglas latchford was indicted
after allegedly trafficking stolen
artifacts
Douglas lashford was a British
businessman lived really his entire
adult life in Bangkok who made a lot of
money in Pharmaceuticals and real estate
and was also the world's most prominent
and and arguably most prolific dealer of
Cambodian statues
Douglas was known derisively among
Heritage activists as Dynamite Doug and
that was for the the rumored means by
which some of his objects were extracted
from temples
Douglas used this term for himself
describing himself as an adventurer
scholar which is is obviously calculated
to to create a kind of Indiana Jones
vibe that was not really him but in fact
Douglas was a guy who liked five-star
hotels and bespoke suits and nice
restaurants this is not someone who was
ever trooping around the jungle In
Search of Lost Treasures he got involved
with something called the Thai
bodybuilding and physique Sports
Association which is the official
National Organization for bodybuilders
in Thailand and Douglas who who by this
point was quite wealthy uh bankrolled
the association he ultimately served as
the president
he was a businessman and he did most of
his business from the comfort of his
home in Bangkok
items that in one way or another pass
through latchford's hands ended up in
the collections of some very wealthy
people ended up in the Metropolitan
Museum in New York in the Norton Simon
in Pasadena California in the British
museum the National Gallery of Australia
we don't actually know how many pieces
he bought and sold certainly in the
hundreds perhaps in the thousands
[Music]
we went into the met and we took 3D
images of every Cambodian piece that's
on display
and fully documented what is here
we will be bringing that back home and
discussing with the team back in Phnom
Penh to analyze I mean closely
scrutinize
you know the details of these objects
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
there's been a big evolution in thinking
around cultural heritage and who it
belongs to
in 1970 there was a convention that was
put together through UNESCO which is the
the UN body for cultural heritage that
laid down some ground rules for how
statues you know paintings cultural
objects essentially can be removed from
their country of origin the basic
principle is
post 1970 you are supposed to show that
you have permission from the government
of the country where an object
originated to remove it there's no
indication that that latchford had
permission the Cambodian government
certainly never granted permission for
the removal of any of these objects
today I am proud to announce that we are
returning 30 ancient works of art to the
kingdom of Cambodia
organized looting networks including
looters affiliated with the Khmer Rouge
sent these statues to a well-known
Antiquities dealer Douglas latchford
the looters would go get what they could
find and they would bring it to the
brokers who would get it into Thailand
and then ultimately it would find its
way to Douglas
so there is a large team of researchers
centered on an American lawyer named
Bradley Gordon who lives in Cambodia who
are now trying to track down objects
that were looted from Cambodia
this team are interviewing these looters
in great detail going through step by
step everything they remember
they will have a Cambodian government
archaeologists dig up a temple and look
for fragments look for broken feet or
pieces of pedestals
you can 3D match these fragments to what
is known to be in museum collections or
the collections of private collectors
if that works you've found a crime scene
and that as you can imagine provides a
basis to demand that these pieces be
given back because they're stolen
property
when I started I was hired by the U.S
Department of Justice
I went out with cambodians and we went
around the countryside and we met maybe
100 200 Witnesses and we spoke to them
and we found one gentleman in particular
and we call him the lion
he moved up to become the head of a
major gang and he had more than 300 400
people working for him across the
country and he told me that the one
thing that kept him going was the demand
that people in Bangkok and one person in
particular named Sia Ford who was
latchford was eager to get khmeric
Antiquities
when I met the lion I brought one of the
books that latchford had published and
he got very excited when he saw the
front cover he saw shivanskonda a father
and child statue extremely important
statue and he was excited and saying to
his wife I know this statue I know this
statue and later he showed me the spot
where he found it
and we dug and we found the arm and we
found the air
I think Luther now they they want to
help us because they feel
more likely they feel guilty
they feel so sad when
everything just gone they know also that
those Antiquity gone from Cambodia and
its result from their activity from
their mistake also
today I'm at the stone laboratory of the
national museum in Phnom Penh and behind
me is Shiva with the Statue of skanda
[Music]
we brought one of lions lieutenants to
This Very Room a couple months ago and
he saw shivan's Ganda and he touched it
and he said I believe you know
I understand what you're doing and I see
the results
and they continue to help us
from about 2016 when a very prominent
New York Antiquities dealer named Nancy
weiner was charged criminally with
possession of stolen goods Douglas knew
that he was in the crosshairs and he
began working to try and head it off
through these negotiations with the
Cambodian government and his ask of the
Cambodian government was that in
exchange for me giving back my
collection I want you to ask the
Americans not to prosecute
one day a couple years ago my phone rang
and I answered the phone and it was
Douglas he had instructions not to talk
to me at that stage so he called me and
he said I'm back from the dead
and he started laughing and we started
talking
he was an extremely Charming Man and a
very good salesman and there's no
question about that and I said to him
look Douglas we need your collection to
come home
and if you truly love the Cambodian
people this would be the right thing to
do and he laughed and he said yes
I I would like to give back to Cambodia
I now have access to a lot of his
correspondence
and I see that sadly he was actually
selling his collection he was trying to
get rid of it and putting in other
people's hands
you know he was
extremely busy trying to move his
collection right up until the end
it's kind of sad you know for us as a
Cambodian who have a very long very
great history but now with the same to
lost it we become
someone who have nothing the Antiquity
is important because they are not the
statue they are not the object
they are belonged to and our ancestor
so that is important that the statue
that the Antiquity can back our ancestor
came back to Earth and then we can
continue our practice our worship
in many ways our work is just getting
started we're tracking more than 100
museums with more than 2 000 objects now
there are some major collections out
there so we're taking a strong line when
we're talking to museums and we're
talking to private collectors we're
saying prove to us you have a right to
have it it's stolen we know it's stolen
some of the museums are being very
transparent and forthcoming and friendly
about the situation and open to the
discussion others are stonewalling they
don't want to talk to us the U.S
government has contacted private
collectors and they've had a lot of
incredible successes you know we had Jim
Clark returning a collection that he
paid more than 35 million dollars for
returning this artifact is like
returning our pride returning our soul
back to our peoples it's been very
frustrating because we're doing all this
work here in Cambodia in a country that
is still developing without full
cooperation from extremely sophisticated
and Wealthy institutions and without the
help of private collectors many of them
are billionaires these individuals 100
of them I know their names I have their
email addresses they're out there they
are completely silent none of them
are coming forward and providing us
information if we had all that
information
I think we could prove to almost every
Museum in the world most of their
collection is stolen it needs to come
home
so what I walk into my museum and I saw
these females that you Kake style so I
feel very very proud feeling like miss
each other
like my heart like show up I love this
statue so much when I see I never think
about I have chance to see this statue
yes very absence
if I don't have chance to visit here I
don't know where this stats you've gone
and also Cambodian
Young Generation New Generation no
chance to see the real statue in our
country
[Music]